i always want my kids to just see the
best of the best
so i just try to as hard as it can be
sometimes i do try to ignore it and just
try to do whatever's best for the kids
that's what i love about you because
take the high road yeah
kim kardashian opens up about taking the
high road amid all the drama with her
estranged husband kanye west you just
gotta roll with it
over the past few weeks the former
couple has been publicly feuding on
social media with yay launching a whole
bunch of accusations at kim on instagram
and trashing her boyfriend saturday
night live star pete davidson both
online and on his track easy god sent me
from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
kim has mostly kept quiet about it but
on thursday fans got a sneak peek at the
41 year old kkw beauty founder's
upcoming chat with ellen degeneres set
to air april 13th kim says her number
one priority is protecting the four
children she shares with yay north saint
chicago and salm something she learned
from her own parents divorce i always
saw such a good example in my mom and my
dad in their relationship so i'm always
just hopeful and no matter what goes on
you know it's the father of my kids i'll
always be protective all that echoes
what kim's younger sister chloe told et
about their parents co-parenting style
back in 2019. i think everyone has to
handle their co-parenting situation in
their own style but my mom and my dad
were like that it took them years but my
dad would come over once a week for
family dinners and would play golf with
my stepdad and we come from a family
where we believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be as for the beauty mogul she
says when it comes to the tough times
she just tries to focus on how she can
use it to make her better i also think
sometimes these are like lessons this
was put in my life for a reason and
these challenges and as hard as it is i
try to like sit still sometimes and say
okay what is this lesson what am i meant
to learn from it and how can i just like
get through it and that's like the whole
message that i just try to take away
from anything not going your way in life
is just try to learn move on and be a
good person and happiness is exactly
what she found with her new bow yep in
another clip from the reality stars sit
down with ellen kim revealed that pete
not only has a few tattoos dedicated to
her i think my favorite one
it says here it says my girl is a lawyer
he also has her name branded on his
chest
yeah you heard me not tattooed branded
he was like i want something that's
there that i can't you know get rid of
my tattoos he's like i don't want to be
able to get rid of it or to cover it up
and i just wanted it like there as like
a scar
on me
of course this all comes after the
couple went instagram official last week
i have the cutest pictures of us and i
want to be like oh my god we're so cute
and i want you know but then i'm like
you know
don't be so desperate don't be posting
so much just give a glimpse
and while fans might be hoping to catch
a glimpse of their relationship when the
kardashians new hulu series premieres
april 14th kim recently told variety she
hasn't filmed with pete yet but she's
not opposed to it
why not
don't worry though the beauty mogul also
teased that she will share all the juicy
details on the new show like how they
met and how it all went down
and based on the newest trailer of the
kardashians she wasn't lying who are you
texting kim does his name rhyme with
feet
[Music]
you